the Joe Rogan experience I've got an
idea
fabric wear my special February 7th and
8th I will at the end of that special
start gaining weight first one to pass
me for real for real
186 damn look how slim you are when I
met my wife
damn you get those [ __ ] well she
signed on for a raw deal yeah it's got a
Penny's back I will gain weight Nissan
Segura have you ever seen Tom's jawline
he looks like [ __ ] magnum p.i when he
was skinny 7th grade bro I'm telling you
right now a very very attractive man I
believe you fine scan it you tell me
where can we find that pic you know you
know where you can find that actually
pouty lips look at you
his arm I've got a scar on a play like
that ari come on hammer yeah good yeah
who's that guy in the left pretend to be
you look at that what is that [ __ ]
good is that [ __ ] guy it's a fake you
get your t-shirt I'm great how great is
that title for now what is it shirt no
idea that title was great I remember
that CD thrill out in the early 2000
right 2010 oh [ __ ] yeah good-looking Tom
right there that's the one I fell in
love with I remember exactly when that
was when was that that wasn't Russell
Peters show on Showtime
simple on your chin on your cheek 2009
so the thing about weight loss is if you
guys just do the weight loss thing and
just get down and wait for a day or a
couple days that doesn't help anybody it
doesn't know what it what if you could
keep it off that's the health that's the
key what is your thing what keeps you
eating like what is your
what's your your vice for me it's pasta
its carbs when I when I eat a lot of
carbs it's just like [ __ ] I can't help
myself sometimes yeah I would say it's
probably carb related like I like rice
red pasta hot pasta yeah yeah I love it
sure I mean I'm not a crazy sugar if it
like sweet to you a lot I'm a glutton to
I [ __ ] I eat and I'm stuffed and I
just keep eating I don't really do that
as much anymore I used I used to do that
all that I used to think that's how
meals were completed like every meal but
that's like I would say at my worst but
I don't think I really eat like that
most of the time now mmm but I don't you
know I'm not like weighing out
everything as much as I should you know
so you could just cut back your portions
I could I'd you know and you'd probably
still be fine you probably wouldn't feel
like you're denying yourself anything
yeah I think so yeah yeah that's how I
always feel I always feel like to like
I'll get on a good meal plan and it's
just about the discipline of sticking to
it and then you know start doing it less
are you wait you're doing now you're
gonna go he goes on how much did you pee
Wow yeah you're I understand my problem
with weight loss I don't understand
yours you just boobs yeah - you're not a
booze thing right now so it's more than
booze is that is that it's the things
that booze invites into my life
late-night food is rough but also the
the empty calories of empty calories 7
Cal around you lost like [ __ ] 30
pounds by not drinking yeah
what is yours yeah it's food yeah so if
you lost 30 pounds from not drinking
you'd be 207 you're on 205 s door just
knocking at it yeah but I don't know
what like Tom because Tom does not look
what I believe had dinner a bunch of
times someone he's a gluttonous heater
like he says that you have had dinner a
bunch of times tonight
I ate with Ralphie man and he would
[ __ ] he would like
jaw drop you on food it was crazy it was
great he went to katana once and he
ordered like like everything and then it
was like oh that's great we're all good
egos no no that's my order now you guys
put it your dude that's my it might the
sushi or the Bert's sushi experience
with Ralphie is my favorite story
because of the whole thing is that Bert
is like you're an opening act at the
time that was opening for him and and
Ralphie is inviting Bert and his wife
and like Bert and you know Bert's or Lee
Ann or Ralphie's wife they're all having
dinner Ralphie's paying all the time
like for meals for men they're in Hawaii
no no no sorry Bahamas Obama's yeah and
then for like one the next night bursts
like I'm gonna cover like a respectful
thing you know you've bought all these
dinners I'm taking you to dinner tonight
and they go to sushi sex Ralphie Ralphie
started ordering and they're bringing
boats out like the boats with all the
sushi and you guys are jumping in and
you don't realize it's all for him well
it's just like he's ordering he's just
ordering but and I know I'm paying for
it but he's just ordering he's like I
got this playa and I was like all right
cool and he just kept ordering and
ordering and I'm I'm eating and I'm
drinking and then keep going I like you
telling the story but it makes me laugh
because Ralphie had treated you guys
just like four meals and then you're
just like I shouldn't be I've been in
this position before to where somebody
is like you know you you want to be like
you know what like I'm a [ __ ] man and
I mean you're you know I'm gonna gum it
up by dinner now tonight's my night but
you're not in a position to take this
bill so like they bring the bill and
it's a [ __ ] four-figure bill this is
over a thousand
dollar sushi experience and then you
insist on paying and Lee Ann Lee knows
how much is it they go go [ __ ] yourself
that's how much it is and she goes you
don't talk to me like that and I go go
[ __ ] yourself again they'll talk to me
eat and ravi goes our play should he
just let me pay for a player like and
she goes why are you talking like this
and i'm looking at like a [ __ ]
fifteen hundred dollar bill twelve
twelve hundred he was $1200 or $1500 i I
didn't have the money in the bank
account to pay for the tip it was like
that cuz I [ __ ] I think my the the
story always hits me is cuz I feel
myself doing this thing I would do the
same thing oh yeah
Rafi was so generous like he just was so
generously you felt I don't I don't want
you to think I'm taking advantage of you
I want you to know that I'm your friend
and I want to pay for things too mmm
[ __ ] yeah that was a bit and
that happen Ralph he goes wow Leanne's
irate at me storms off
Rafi goes ah player we go win it back on
blackjack took your thousand dollars out
maybe two thousand dollars out of the
bank machine go to roulette put on black
hits red all I remember is we were the
couple in the lobby fighting it's like
you bad everybody you can't even like
save with the hotel when Ralph you walk
past me and it was not a drop in the
bucket throughout from those two
thousand dollars and he just saw me
fight with Lana goes Oh miss LeAnn give
him a break he tried his best he tried
his best I see on the plane Playboy and
then Ralph is on the plane you know sir
my whole part of the story that I
remember the most
ralphie read a book on a flight from
Miami to LA he read the whole [ __ ]
book I've never read a [ __ ] book in
five hours he was like a really like he
read a book I remember sitting next to
me read a book that's a crazy part of
the story I remember no really damn he
was very generous you were broke
yeah we were broke man yeah that's Burt
that's Burt I like to roll the dice yeah
yeah it's working you don't become a
comedian if you don't like rolling the
dice man
I don't think so gotta be
crazy your comic you're a little crazy
you have to be you have to be a little
crazy and if you're not crazy I don't I
don't I don't know if I want to know you
[Applause]